[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
bring in jay bilas espn's college
basketball analyst
jay walker's through yesterday what did
it mean to you what's it mean to the
sports uh world of the ncaa
well it it was a profound error in
judgment
on the part of the ncaa to petition the
supreme court
uh to hear that case because the the
lower court ruling in the ninth circuit
was actually pretty good for the ncaa
and it preserved amateurism
and what the ncaa considers its right to
limit players
compensation uh from schools and from
third parties so that was that was the
first thing that hit me was how stupid
and incompetent
it was for the ncaa to take that step
but really dan what this was about was
you know this the supreme court
uh took this case because there was a
circuit split
among federal courts with regard to how
these cases were being decided
and so what the ncaa really lost was
its deference from the courts and the
presumption
that their rules were were pro
competitive
and so now they're gonna now every case
they're gonna have to go through this
rule what's called a rule of reason test
which means they're gonna have to show
uh and and prove that they're they're
pro aspects to what they're doing and
not anti-competitive
and like what you just read from justice
kavanaugh's concurring opinion
it's going to be really hard for them to
do that i don't think they're going to
be able to and
and so that was a huge mistake they made
i think what this does now is it opens
the door
for further litigation that's not just
going to be on
you know laptop it's not going to be
about laptops and tutors and
internships it's going to be about name
image and likeness and it's going to be
about
contracting with the university for pay
and there's no
i don't think there's any way that the
ncaa is going to prevail on these cases
going forward and the only hope they
have
is going on both knees to congress and
saying please give us an anti-trust
exemption which you've given to no
other multi-billion dollar business in
the country please give it to us
because we've proven that we can do this
right
and then i don't think they're going to
get that either what if the ncaa hired
you
as a lawyer and said make a case for us
what would you lead what well i would
have i would have said leave it alone
we we won substantial parts
of the case in in the ninth circuit
we lost a few few elements of it but
overall this was good
overall the o'bannon ruling was good
because it it
continues to allow the ncaa
to place cartel restrictions on athletes
like you just said that would be allowed
in no other business
that the courts are still allowing us to
violate federal anti-trust law and we
are a serial
federal anti-trust law violator
uh so let's let's take what we got and
keep quiet and lay in the weeds and keep
doing what we're doing that's what i
would have told them
what if they hired you today i'd say
you're done now it's over now
you have no shot that you did something
so incompetent that you're not going to
be able to survive this now
so now now you really have to turn your
attention toward congress
and and really dan so this is going to
end this ruling the austin ruling by the
supreme court is going to essentially
stop
the ncaa's name image and likeness uh
legislation in its tracks
they're not going to pass anything now
now i i said it back in october of
2019 they're not going to do anything
they're there's the ncaa is going to say
they're going to do it they're not going
to do anything because they don't want
to
i think that was proven right but now
what they're what they're going to do is
that
now they're going to say if we pass
anything
that's restrictive we're going to be
right back in front of
in front of a court and we're going to
lose so they're probably just going to
say
all right everybody can do what their
state allows
and they'll just beg congress for a
federal law that's going to preempt all
these state laws give them one national
standard
and hopefully for from their perspective
give them the continuing right
to limit athletes in a way that the
supreme court just said that justice
kavanaugh just said would be illegal
in any other business in america so
that's now their their their stance
is let us do something that the highest
court in the land says is illegal for
any other business can you imagine
being in that position now and and the
incompetence
of of that decision making i just cannot
imagine
but i wonder with these states that are
going to have a head start with some of
the other states
in recruiting you know texas now
you bring in recruits you can pay them
uh you know are schools going to have an
image
advisor on staff you know how do you get
paid off of this
you have to do it legally i don't know
it just feels like some states are going
to have
a little bit of an opportunity here
where the other states are not do you
see that maybe but so what that's what
competition looks like like we've got
differing you know the funny part of
this dan is because we've had this
system for so long
uh people are going well how's this
gonna work what's gonna happen it's so
complicated how are we gonna do not that
you're doing this but but that's
you know it's like breathless and we've
had
drastic change on the revenue side since
1984
and nobody asks how it's going to work
like nobody says well how are we going
to pay all our coaches like
do we pay all the coaches the same what
do we give coach k the same as we give
john shire like what do we do what do we
do
you know it it's really not that big of
a deal and it it
it'll work just fine we have differing
tax laws in every state
different different state tax laws so in
florida and texas and nevada
there's no state tax at all and you
don't hear anybody saying
wait a minute that's not fair that's not
fair because now they can offer coaches
more compensation they're
all the best coaches are just going to
coach in states with no
uh income tax it it's all fine it's
it may be a factor it's not that big of
a deal and name image and likeness
if one state differs from another it'll
all work itself out
uh other states may increase what they
allow
we'll be fine we don't need a national
standard with regard to speed limits we
don't need it with regard to taxation
and we don't need it with regard to name
image likeness it is just the ncaa
saying
the sky is falling the sky is falling we
have to be allowed to do this or
it's going to be a problem but if you
looked at it on the revenue generation
side
like this this college sports have
changed incredibly
in the last 40 years since the last time
the ncaa was before the supreme court
and
lost as an anti-trust violator uh and
but nobody's had a problem with it and
the business has thrived
and it'll thrive now it is not that big
of a deal
that that the the players are on the way
to getting their civil right
to be treated just like everyone else
including every other student and one
last thing dan
there are far more non-athlete students
that get scholarships than athletes
so when we start trying to shoehorn this
whole thing into saying well the
scholarship is pay
well then what is a scholarship to a
non-athlete and why aren't
why aren't they restricted in what they
can earn or accept while they're in
school
you know the only the only person that's
restricted in any way
is an athlete and i i've happened to
think it's profoundly wrong and has been
forever
and the supreme court just said it's
profoundly wrong and
and every court in the land now has
heard that
and the ncaa is not going to get
protection from the courts anymore
that part of it is over and it's over
because of their incompetence
and the timing of this because the ncaa
might be voting on that 12 team playoff
today
which is going to generate even more
revenue
and so i just that juxtaposition of you
know these athletes saying hey can we
get paid
uh hey hold off guys we gotta we gotta
vote on this 12 team playoff here
funny how that's not too complicated i
mean remember when
remember when everybody said well we
can't have a playoff because the bull
system it's impossible
and they turned around did it made a
billion dollars the first year
um you know the revenue generation side
nothing's too complicated they can
figure it all out
and so now we're asking these
ridiculously stupid questions about
well how we going to pay everybody do we
pay everybody the same how do we value
it the school has value
like if you if you applied that to
coaches
what we say about players you go well
how are we going to figure this out do
we pay all the coaches the same
uh you know what are we going to do do
we pay the head coach the same as an
assistant coach what about the coach's
secretary that works just as hard
we don't do that these schools know
exactly whom to recruit and exactly whom
to put in the game when they want to win
they know whom to pay and how much it is
not this hard
and it's in the ncaa's interest to make
it seem complicated
it's not complicated it's just business
and they'll figure it out just fine um
you know we had we had uh
conference realignment and and nobody
stopped watching
we have coach when i played for coach k
back in the 80s he probably made 50 60
000 bucks
he's making 10 million now nobody
stopped watching
we flew commercial and rode on buses
they fly private now
nobody stopped watching uh and they're
not going to stop watching if
a player can do it if trevor lawrence
can do a commercial they're not going to
stop watching
so you know this is all nonsense and the
supreme court called it out as such
what happens next well i think what
happens next is the ncaa puts the brakes
on their name image and likeness
legislation
and they basically just say
um every school can do now what their
state law
allows them to do and it won't run afoul
of ncaa bylaws
and they'll see what happens and then
they'll go to congress and they'll keep
lobbying congress to say please please
please bail us out of this situation
that we created
and give us rules even though we say
we're just like you
and we're a representative government
pass a law so that we don't have to do
anything anymore
and i think it's going to be really hard
for congress to give them a safe harbor
in antitrust law when the supreme court
just said no you're a multi-billion
dollar business
you know what the rest of us have to do
we have to navigate our business lives
without violating federal anti-trust law
we don't we don't get congress telling
us no go ahead you can do that
uh we none of our media companies don't
have to do it's amazing how we do that
it's amazing how you and i can get paid
and and our companies don't have to go
to congress and say please
please give us a state a law that that
gives us safe harbor for all this
i don't think the ncaa is going to get
that they're asking for extraordinary
relief here
they may get a law that uh that
you know sort of allows the same thing
for every state
but it's gonna be way more than the ncaa
wants and uh and i'm just i'm
flabbergasted
that that of the incompetence of ncaa
leadership
that that they drove us into this ditch
intentionally
uh and and through inaction all these
years
and didn't change while they were while
they were changing
the game themselves they didn't change
the game in this area
knowing that it was going to be a
problem and uh
and i'm i'm i just i'm still my jaws on
the floor
how stupid ncaa leadership has been
if we created a sports supreme court are
you willing to be uh justice
do i get a cool robe yes i'll give you a
rope
yeah man i would i would be happy to be
chief justice
thank you jay we appreciate your time as
always
always a pleasure to talk about legal
issues with you dan and
what's better than a good supreme court
opinion yeah generate a lot of
discussion yes
thank you jay that's uh jay bilas from
the mothership college basketball
analyst